[Music]
Rocketman this particular song for
something more than free there are two
things that happened at the same time
that I thought were unrelated until I
actually started the process of writing
the song I was on the phone with my dad
and he works six hours I mean six days a
week sometimes seven days a week and he
does maintenance at a hospital and my
sister she and my stepmom go to church
on Wednesdays on Sunday mornings dad
works all week so you know Sunday's his
only data sleep past five o'clock a.m.
and get up and go take a nap you know
and drink a cup of coffee and then take
a third nap you know so I was on the
phone with him in and he was he was
saying you know wish I could go to
church with him I think I probably
should be but I'm just too exhausted
every Sunday to do that and it occurred
to me and I thought and what kind of
position is that to be in we you know
you're really grateful for having this
job that prevents you from being
grateful in public about it and the way
that people in my part of the country
normally show their gratitude by going
to church and giving thanks with their
community for something like that and
then also the first line of this song
which I did not realize that the two
were going to be related but the first
the Oh
[Music]
bust up something
before
build again that came to me before the
rest of the song did and I was so
thankful for that line I was traveling
somewhere I was I think I was probably
on a flight when that happened and just
wrote it down and it was one of those
lines and I know these are going to work
out well when I don't have to record any
sound when I can just write write it
down on a piece of paper and I don't
forget in the melody I get home from
work I'll call up all my friends
bust up something beautiful left build
again
now get home to work inside somebody's
home now
see they never finds the name and the
free train needs rain and I'm doing what
I wanna sir
I don't think I'm here with Hertz lucky
to have work Sunday morning I'm too
tired of oh thank god
thank God
[Music]
I get mad
[Music]
sit back in my chair and son
[Music]
Rock spring
[Music]
boxes on the trucks there's someone
else's say see them
[Music]
and the four
hands up I guess I'm
I don't think we're hurt
[Music]
every night I dream I'm grounded thank
God every day we'll find somebody
but man
my back is
my
[Music]
I don't think lucky to have work Sunday
morning I'm too tired to go but I thank
God
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]